ouais moi je connais la wii la borne va
du côté le derby du lecteur pas parce
que c'est ce que j'ai l'habitude de
faire mais à la base de l'art de
l'intérieur dassin trille or là je
considère aucun souci pareil mais je
pense à beaucoup je vais essayer de
faire ça 12 septembre 2019
j'ai enfin réussi à obtenir
l'autorisation qu'il me fallait
aujourd'hui je vais pénétrer dans un
lieu le plus sacré de cette cité le silo
j'ai déjà rencontré ce mot à d'autres
occasions
si l'os emploi semble-t-il pour désigner
une construction servant à conserver du
crin pour ce peuple
le grain est remplacé par des livres ici
on ne vit pas on ne mange pas on ne joue
pas non plus ici on lit on écrit on
réserve
telle est la coutume dans ce haut lieu
du savoir où l'on vénère cote grande
déesse de l'ordre de la protection et de
la connaissance
ce temple que les natifs appel
bibliothèque de la part-dieu comporte
trois parties
deux grandes unités latéral qui
accueille la population venue se
recueillir et au centre une immense tour
trésor qui contient semble-t-il leurs
reliques tout savoir et la connaissance
de ce peuple
le quotidien est strictement rythmée par
une pendule sorte de sculpture que l'on
accroche traditionnellement au mur en
hauteur visible de tous et qui semble
donner des points de repère dans
l'écoulement de la journée
[Musique]
lorsque 10 00 s'affiche sur cette sorte
de fétiches les portes du temple s'ouvre
et déjà les fidèles se pressent à
l'intérieur afin de reprendre leur
occupation de la veille
donc à la table 14 vous allez monsieur
celui dont je vous disais que de temps
en temps il piquer un roupillon d'alors
de fauteuils rouges pour avoir accès aux
silos il a un rite de passage auquel je
dois me plier
il consiste à se présenter devant
l'hôtel où un membre de la communauté
vous accueille et vous tend un petit
papier et c'est là que les choses se
compliquent
il faut prendre le bic c'est comme ça
qu'ils nomment ces petits tubes attaché
au cordon de bimétalliques est relié à
un socle qui j'ai remarqué est toujours
positionné à droite du comptoir
j'en déduis donc qu'il n'y pas de gauche
et parmi eux ensuite il faut bien appuyé
sur la fiche avec instruments pour
imprimer ses deux filles et deux numéros
et de lettres dont le sens nous échappe
sjg 615 slash un tir et tes points 0,1
après cette phase de négociation je
pénètre enfin dans le sanctuaire de 17
étages comprenant 60 km linéaires de
rayonnages tous pleins le grand chef de
la communauté dont le titre honorifique
et responsable adjoint du fonds ancien
ma compagne et m'explique le mythe de
fondation du silo à livres il a été
construit dans les temps anciens avec
des matériaux primitifs de la terre et
du fer
cette construction l'intriguent
armatures métalliques particulièrement
fine ne semble pas fait pour résister au
feu pourtant leur pire ennemi le chef me
confiant la tradition explique que si
par malheur le démon du feu se propage à
deux étages au même moment la structure
pourrait fondre et détruire toute la
tour trésor une autre chose attire mon
attention
des hommes armés d'outils s'affairent
dans un recoin de la tour en
m'approchant je comprends qu'ils ne font
pas partie du personnel du silo des
appartiennent à la caste des artisans et
sont venus pour combattre un autre mâle
redoutable l'amiante
la légende dit qu'il est présent dans
les murs du bâtiment et qu'à la moindre
faille ou fissures il peut s'échapper et
répandre le chaos sur son passage
quiconque entre en contact avec
l'amiante risque une mort prématurée
quelque peu apeurée je constate que
cette prophétie n'effraie pas les
bibliothécaires
leur principale inquiétude et la
poussière que génèrent les artisans et
qui se dépose sur la précieuse ouvrage
qu'on a raison d'encourager les grands
bleus français en quittant le silo
j'aperçois des lecteurs dans la grande
salle se doute-t-il de ce qui se trame
dans les coulisses des difficultés
qu'implique chaque demande auprès du
fonds ancien la tradition du peuple de
la part dieu est soumise à rude épreuve
la modernité a désormais atteint cette
contrée reculée et l'a changée à jamais
leurs coutumes j'aurais eu la chance de
pouvoir les observer une dernière fois
voilà monsieur bonjour nous parlions des
habitués de la salle
c'est dans le top 10 il ne pouvait pas
rater
alors à demain donc
[Musique]